good evening thanks for joining us here
at five o'clock i'm denise feldas and
i'm brian loftis a tense situation in
the northeast valley ended with a gunman
dead and a hostage safe vanessa murphy
is live near charleston and sloan in the
northeast valley with the very latest
for us vanessa
one man is dead after police say he
pointed his weapon at officers and a
woman he had just kidnapped they say
this started around nine this morning
near lake mead and jones and then ended
over here with that deadly shooting
captain carlos hank says an armed
suspect kidnapped an ex-girlfriend metro
officers tracked them down near
charleston and sloan according to hank
officers tried to de-escalate the
situation the suspect pointed his weapon
at officers they opened fire the suspect
pronounced dead at the scene the woman
is safe and no officers are hurt this
northeast valley intersection blocked
off as a crime scene for most of tuesday
with a heavy police presence including
csi the mobile command unit and the
police union per department policy metro
is expected to release more information
later this week
and this is still an active scene with
police still here you can see the crime
scene tape is over here and again that
police presence continues past this
strip mall over here we know the
coroner's office is at the scene at the
moment reporting live in the northeast
valley vanessa murphy live local now